donner du sang des litres et des litres
de sang c'est un effort de guerre il est
urgent
Anastasia le fait par devoir patriotique
c'est aussi l'équivalent de sauver un
frère un père ou un nom
car ici chaque personne qui fait la file
connaît quelqu'un sur la ligne de front
les combats les plus intenses sont à
moins de 30 km nous sommes à nicolaïve
la ville d'où s'organise la
contre-offensive pour regagner le sud de
l'Ukraine elle est tombée
un des rares soldats qui a accepté de
parler à la caméra il est un officier
sur la deuxième ligne de défense est
tenu au secret pour ne pas compromettre
l'opération militaire
mais cet appel au don de sang en dit
long sur les blessés qui augmentent il
espère se reposer quelques heures quoi
qu'ici aussi on ne dort jamais
tranquille la ville rempart de Nicolae
avait constamment la cible des
bombardements russes
il y a même pas 24 heures le missile est
tombé ici en pleine rue endommagée tous
les immeubles autours
quatre ONG se partagent cette seule
intersection ici aussi il faut faire
vite au cas où les sirènes se
déclenchent on peut supporter la fin les
pénuries d'eau mais les bombes
j'en peux plus
quelques minutes plus tard une série
d'explosion on voit tout le monde aux
abris
[Musique]
c'est la terreur quotidienne avec
laquelle en attendant que ça se calme
Nicolas il joue sur son téléphone sa
mère reprit beaucoup de gens nous disent
oui on a peur on vient se protéger ici
dans les sous-sols et les abris mais on
se dit en tout cas pour se remonter le
moral bah ce sont les Ukrainiens qui
repoussent les Russes c'est ça qui tient
la population en vie
et la vie reprend là où nous l'avons
laissé
où on distribue de l'aide humanitaire
cette femme
est un consulat
elle était venue au centre de dents pour
chercher des bottes pour un ami mais on
lui a dit qu'il est mort au combat
je vous en supplie donnez-leur des
missiles des munitions ce dont ils ont
besoin pour nous défendre
Nicolas est un con ce qui lui aussi sans
expérience envoyer en renfort pour tenir
tête heureuse il n'est que de passage
pour prendre de l'eau et ravitailler les
trous on lui demande comment elles vont
il évoque les blessés
il y en a trop
mais on tient
non ici